I know he was shot oh you know he was I
literally spoke okay I found out the
same day that his mother found out like
this is how much of a shock this was
Ravi Juliet
thank you for being here first of all
korie's thanks for having us traveling
we're gonna get literally right into the
heart of everything
are you currently together are you
dating no you know what happened well
you're gonna see like specifically what
happens on the show but I broke up with
him and we'll see why and then things
got a little awkward but you're gonna
see how it all kind of plays out on the
show but now we're not together but
we're we don't we're not enemies right
no no how did you take it when she broke
up with you uh you know with a grain of
salt and it's something that you're
gonna obviously see play out as well
yeah I didn't take it lightly
whether were there tears were you mad
you weren't like it's cool whatever
you're definitely not doing that that we
know that you'll see I was very cool
calm and collected but we'll see okay
great well see who's side actually
prevails here I do think this is your
third reality show where you've sort of
been in a romance right you did the
Bachelorette you did Vanderpump did she
approach you to come on this show like
had you guys been dating prior to
filming season three or did you sort of
finagle your way on three yeah we met
before
season 3 started filming and then the
opportunity arose and it was like you
said not unfamiliar ground for me to try
to find love on TV and so went out there
and shot my shot well what I feel like
essentially they wanted they were
interested in Robbie because Robbie and
Kelsie were friends and they knew that
there was that connection there and then
before we started filming Kelsey and I
went out to California to go to
stagecoach I met Robbie we instantly
connected and then I think after that he
was like yeah I'll do the show with you
yeah sure okay how long were you guys
actually together when you were together
like was like a month and a half of like
honeymoon we just were two we were
together every day we went to Greece
right we saw
coming up we were had sleepovers every
night you know I was like yeah it's
inseparable for a while too fast and
then we crashed okay it was a lot like
it's really hard to like maintain a
relationship on a reality TV show why is
that because a lot of people get in the
way
stress is high and there were you know
there were things that had been
unfinished in my life and things I
needed to like properly handle and to
bring Robbie into that was just a little
too much for me so did Alex was he sort
of part of the equation when it came to
the breakup he was yeah he was there
were other things as well but I think at
the same time like I had been in a
relationship for like two years
mmm and then to jump right back into
another one like wasn't the smartest
thing to do okay I think everyone can
agree with that any time yeah you seem
very mature right now like you've
learned a lot oh my god 20:19 was the
best year the braking needs to opening
yeah when you were talking about Alex
just now you had kind of a smirk on your
face why is that
oh just he's kind of always in the
middle of everything throughout the
season and you'll kind of see that yeah
well we do know he's expecting yes he is
expecting how was that for you to hear
it was hard it was definitely hard I
mean everyone can think I'm very petty
for saying this but this is the actual
reality he basically knocked up his
rebound and it was - I think it was too
soon for me cuz we he basically got
another girl pregnant the same year we
broke up so which is a fact and that was
a lot for me but I'm actually like
definitely healing okay no I'm getting
better and it just takes time you know
like it was a lot and she's I mean
you'll see on the season to her and I
are fine in the beginning she was like
very aware of the situation we were all
in and then it kind of slowly tension
started to get high as she definitely
got feelings for him and he was just the
same Alex he had always been constantly
lying constant
like all of that yeah I mean we know
he's cheated on you that's been
addressed right on the show before do
you think he had cheated on you with
this girlfriend
we caught girlfriend well they're
they're more than girlfriend and
boyfriend I would think I hope at this
point I don't think he cheated on me
with her but he definitely cheated on
her with me Oh but and then I don't want
to like say too much but you'll see how
it plays out
this was before he got her pregnant and
this was when they were dating for like
two months so do you think now that
there is a child on the way that he can
change that's my question
well we'll see and I really do hope like
I always have said Alex be a great
father I think he will be a great father
and I also think this girl is really
good for him she's a lot more into his
lifestyle than I am like Alex and I were
always very different and I think that's
why we clashed a lot she's definitely
calmer than I am in ways I think she
also accepts more things than I do
mmm but um yeah I wish him the best and
you know this is this is his path now
and I hope that everything works out for
him so no chance that you guys ever get
back together I mean I'm I'm 22 and I
don't have any desire to be a stepmother
and why I mean why would I want to be
with a person like that yeah yeah do you
think he was shocked that he was gonna
become a father I know he was shocked
oh you know he was I literally spoke
okay I found out the same day that his
mother found out like this is how much
of a shock this was to everyone I spoke
to his father about it and in these
types of situations you simply asked are
you keeping the child she says yes or no
she says yes then you are going to be a
father that's how it works he has no
choice and I mean it he's not gonna say
he was ready to have a child like that's
just not true mm-hmm I hope he's
accepting the situation he's in and
going to give it everything he has how
are you guys these days like are you
have not talked in a long time since
when
September okay the last thing we said to
each other was like I hate you some cuss
words that was the last conversation you
had are we gonna see that on our station
on the show I think it was filmed it was
really really not like not pretty to
watch but I think that they're gonna
definitely show some of that yeah it
gets really really hated yeah yeah
Robbie what is your relationship or
friendship like with alex is there one
no there's not and I was about to touch
in and there won't be in the future
either but I have to hope that he can
kind of overcome this type of
decision-making process that he's in and
and be that person that now it's not
just him in his life it's right there's
other people that he depending on him is
there oh I was gonna say no he was he
was very very mean to Robbie he would
comment on Robbie's Instagram photos of
us and like throughout the relationship
really although the entire time and then
I actively tried to keep them separated
because I know Alex and I know that he
would try to hit Robbie and when he
finally did see Robbie like several
months into dating Alissa he slopped
Robbie in the face wait he on the show
he hits you there's a couple instances
yeah we won't give away too much okay
but Wow
so now I get why you're not friends with
him that makes sense oh yeah and he does
seem kind of jealous oh yeah from what
we've seen so far and even the extended
trailer and it's rough yeah how has it
been for you with people questioning
your intentions I mean I kind of knew it
was gonna happen when we walked in I
don't think why why did you know uh just
being around Chloe in them I was
familiar with who they were as people
and then you know starting to date
Juliet and going out there she kind of
let me know everything was gonna be a
sort of along those lines and then
knowing that Alex was out of the picture
and I was gonna kind of be stepping into
that was gonna cause issues as well sure
and he's a main part of that friend girl
on that side and I just kind of had to
be ready for it
yeah I think also Robbie had been on
several
LED TV shows now so like all of our
friends we're very aware of that and I
feel like that played a huge part and
also that's just like you said it's
Chloe's personality who's I get involved
and Chloe calls you a cloud chaser
mm-hmm how do you respond to that yeah
that's kind of why I've been so
successful and avoiding this stuff is
because I don't respond to Chloe's
accusations okay I'm gonna let them go
in one ear and out the other
yeah I mean you saw in the first episode
she's like I don't know anything about
this kid I don't know anything about
this kid and then she's talking about
well if you don't know anything about me
don't talk about me like you know yeah
and when you're not the Chloe acts like
my older sister sometimes and also like
my biggest enemy but I mean you see that
throughout our friendship she does care
and I think that her worries were
somewhat genuine but she took it a
little too far I would I would say well
speaking of taking things too far in
this week's episode you and Chloe
actually get into quite the altercation
right that's when she's my biggest out
of me okay okay well how does that
affect the rest of the season and how
intense to things get in that moment
things were incredibly intense in that
moment it caused a lot of issues like
our house was very divided at that point
and it lasted kind of a while but I mean
you see all the ups and downs with our
friend group throughout every season
honestly and and you see how I kind of
tried to mend that issue and you know
how like hard that was dating Robbie
during that time it really divided like
all of our friends up so so what we see
is actually happening within this group
mm-hmm it's not like storylines and
scripted and you can't make this up this
is all yeah I mean I'm not I wouldn't
consider myself an actress that's why I
want him constantly bawling my eyes out
and know that that's real okay okay it
looks like the cops get involved in this
week's episode this is why yeah maybe
maybe I actually I haven't seen the
episode and I also wasn't there when the
cops were getting involved but I heard
about it
we're you or Chloe arrested okay so
there was no actual arrests right yeah
but I know there was no arrests okay how
are you and Chloe these days we're good
you're good yeah through the issue works
through it all and you know we have to
kind of remind ourselves like we've been
friends for so long and we have how to
each other's backs in very serious
situations so right now we're good and
now that alex is having a baby she's
kind of come back to my side a little
bit and oh you won't see yeah how does
she take that oh she's got to be so mad
I would imagine um no I mean she's she's
look she like loves him secretly
uh yeah I think she's over that though
and kind of accepted that that's never
going to happen okay especially now but
I think I took the worst which is like
as to be expected
yeah but it was all a huge shock to all
of us and he's never had a pregnancy
scare before so we never we never have
thought that that was ever gonna be a
thing like when I first found out I
joked about it
I was like we wanted to see having a
baby oh you just never even thought it
was I don't look possum I mean I cuz I
never I was with him for five times as
long as she was with him mm-hmm and I
never got pregnant so I just yeah I
never we never thought all of us were
shocked was there a point where you
thought even despite everything that you
guys had gone through that you would end
up with him
like before before all this happened um
yeah I mean yeah I think yeah there was
probably a part of me that was like oh
it's never really over because it never
really was with him like every time we
would see each other we would act like
things were fine mm-hmm it was like old
times but we never really saw each other
often anyway mm-hmm cuz he knew what he
would do if I was around right kind of
tease the rest of this season and what
we're gonna see with both of you guys
anything you're nervous to see play out
anything you're excited to see you out
I'm nervous for Nashville when we go to
Nashville I why uh-huh think bad things
happen bad things happen I'm nervous for
the gala I'm
tomorrow night's episode okay is I'm
like I've accepted tomorrow night's
episode I'm like I am in the wrong I'm a
progressive TV filming said I've ever
been on
really more so than yeah like she just
said like I skipped out on some of the
later half events and the back half of
filming is that could the bravest
Mormons
some of that some of it just of wanting
to avoid drama that we could see was
coming yeah but yeah it was it was an
intense it was and that's not the only
me we ran away to the beach oh yeah like
after everything went down I was like
alright we need a little break we're
gonna take our mics off and disappeared
for like an hour
and it was like chasing us around we're
like bye I would imagine that would be
her just like on your heart on your
brain and all of the intensity that's
going on all right it all kind of yeah I
mean you'll see how it plays out but it
all kind of started with like my
feelings of the trail by Chloe
so yeah I was really - it was like the
beginning of summer was very hard yeah
okay and we just wanted to be happy and
it didn't it didn't work out I think
timing is everything but yeah you guys
will see it all fail is there a chance
you to get back together ever I don't
think so
no balls in your court yeah I mean it
does feel like things very caning a box
for sure she is entertaining why we love
her okay so the door is open for him but
it's closed for you yeah there you go
I keep moving forward okay was
infidelity a part of us breakup or no no
no so it wasn't like with Alex we're now
no I mean I did not cheat on your valid
you did not cheat on me if Alex was
involved in the break-up
Alex was involved in it okay okay uh-huh
and then before other things too don't
let him fool you can't wait to hear him
live
I do want to ask you quickly about
Madison's new boyfriend how shocked or
how did you feel when she brought
ish into the mix well originally in the
V in the beginning of summer Chloe kept
telling me she had this huge secret she
just had to tell me but she couldn't
tell me and I was like I hate when she
kept the secret I was like I hate when
people say they have a secret and they
don't tell me but I ended up finding out
at the graduation party and I was like
my dog job so I was like I feeling that
they were hooking up uh-huh
I did not know they were dating I did
not know they were in love and I was
just shocked
yeah but I'm happy for them Madison is
an old soul it totally makes sense and I
love it him and I always got along
really well so okay how about before
yeah all right well thank you guys so
much for being here and for being so
open we appreciate how candid you were
make sure you guys tune in to siesta key
on Tuesday nights on MTV
[Music]